[Music]
time for some pft props on this friday
morning and we remind you before we get
started the doug peterson the eagles
head coach in arizona when everybody's
supposed to be kind of relaxed and chill
peterson decided in a very professional
aboveboard way to call out his
quarterback for not being a better
teammate said peterson of carson wentz i
think being a better teammate sometimes
just being a little more vulnerable
being a little more accessible you're
obviously committed to your craft and
developing your skill but it's like you
want to walk across the aisle and talk
to the other side that's all part of the
maturation process and the growth
process it's something you learn through
time carson's got that in him and he
wants carson wants to become a leader
for the whole team a quarterback who
will take over the locker room a
quarterback who will have his players
behind him all the time and we talked
about this earlier big cat one one of
the ways you inspire your teammates is
show that you can make good decisions be
available to play all games because
that's how they had the shrine to nick
foles last year it's because carson
wentz wasn't playing nick foles came in
and played well the players rally around
the guy who's playing so job number one
for wence be available to play
well and job number one for wence you
bring up nick foles i think that was
part of it nick foles by all accounts is
a fantastic teammate a fantastic leader
and a guy who is beloved in that locker
room it's got to be awkward when your
franchise quarterback is not the guy
that everyone likes and it's actually
just the backup so i think nick foles
kind of leaving the addition by
subtraction theory here that carson
wentz will have maybe a little bit
better grasp on the team maybe not as
insecure not saying he was insecure i'm
obviously just guessing on this but if
the guy behind you is is more liked by
all your peers it probably would lead to
some insecurities and probably make it
so that you're not the best teammate so
i think justin by nick foles going down
to jacksonville carson wentz will
already be a better teammate next year
that leads into our pft props this
morning and we're going to begin with
quarterbacks available to play who has
the better chance to play 16 games this
season carson wentz or 49ers quarterback
jimmy garoppolo
i'm saying carson wentz because i don't
know is jimmy garoppolo going to start
the season i don't know about that the
acl tears have now become this thing
adrian peterson ruined it for the rest
of the nfl when he came back in nine
months and everyone talked about how his
his knee was unbelievable everyone just
assumes that you see it with every guy
donovan mcnabb when he tours acl it took
a little time tom brady it took he was a
little rusty when he came back like it
takes a little time not being healthy
and being good again are two different
things so i think the 49ers will make
sure that he's ready to go fully i don't
think he's going to start the season and
i think carson wentz is going to play
all 16 games there's my hot take of the
day
yeah and and look with jimmy garoppolo i
agree with you we never know how long
they're going to put a guy on ice and
adrian peterson did ruin it to a certain
extent we do have this expectation now
that guys are going to be back and
sometimes they aren't sometimes they
aren't and even if garoppolo is healthy
he hasn't proven he can stay healthy he
had that four game audition in 2016 with
the patriots and he got injured in the
second game and opened the door for
jacoby brissette so garoppolo has not
been a guy who has proven to be durable
and i think that is a real concern and
if anyone has an incentive to figure out
how to stay healthy it's carson wentz
who has yet to get his second contract
garoppolo has his he can go out and be
reckless wence is trying to earn his and
one way to earn it is to be healthy and
available to play all right next one
over under game started this year for
quarterback josh rosen currently with
the cardinals who knows who he'll be
playing for in
2019.5 is the over under what do you got
i'm going with the over i'm going with
the over it probably makes no sense but
what were the teams that we said he was
rumored to be possibly linked to the
giants the patriots and the chargers
right
all three of those teams have
very old
very old actually i should say
quarterbacks i think if josh rosen comes
in i would roll the dice on you know all
those guys eli manning peyton man
eli manning philip rivers and tom brady
obviously the starters but i'd roll the
dice on a possible injury or possible
let's see what we have here with josh
rosen he starts one game i'm gonna go
over point five for josh rosen
yeah look i i if he does get traded to
the charger giants or patriots i think
that oh god it depends okay well
hold on if it's hold on let me walk you
through it all right he gets traded to
the chargers phil rivers pretty old he
might have to see he might you know he
might get it but he never does he never
misses he never does he plays with a
torn acl
let me finish chargers going to be good
next year patriots going to be good next
year does a week 17 start when you
already have the buy wrapped up does
that not count as a start because that's
what i'd counted for and if he was on
the giants i think the giants if they
traded for him they would say we're not
going to take dwayne haskins obviously
and josh rosen would definitely get in
probably mid-season when eli manning's
like hey maybe we should not you know
keep trotting eli manning out and
thinking it's gonna the results are
gonna be different i remember last year
after the ravens drafted lamar jackson
and the official over under for him
starting a game was .5 and i said bet
everything you have on the over that all
it takes is one out of 16 and you've
just convinced me all it takes is one
week out of 16. whether it's injury
whether it's the team is great whether
it's we just want to see what this guy
has and with lamar jackson it was you
know maybe he starts the game at
quarterback just as part of a gimmick
package but i've said bet i that was the
strongest i've ever felt about any
potential prop bet in my life so you've
convinced me i don't feel quite as
strongly but you've convinced me josh
rosen over 4.5 wherever he ends up all
right more likely to sign a contract
extension marcus mariota or jameis
winston both are in their fifth year
options and neither has signed a new
contract yet who do you have all right
this one's easy for me as well i think
it's jameis winston and i love mike
frable i think he's going to be a
fantastic coach but when you're talking
about bruce arians the qb whisperer the
guy who has a book named about you know
talking about himself as a qb whisperer
i think that was the biggest reason why
bruce arians both came back why the
bucks signed him or you know brought him
in they're the bruce arians is there to
basically make jameis winston an asset
again and i think that's he's going to
be back he's probably going to be a
long-term deal but i think james winston
will be good enough this year where the
bucks will kick the can down the road
and say we got to keep trying with this
guy he may still be our franchise
quarterback yeah and with marcus mariota
i really do feel like that they're
rooting for him to be the franchise
quarterback in tennessee but when the
owner comes out and says i want him to
become our franchise quarterback look
they know what they have what they don't
have and you've had a change in gm and
had coached multiple times since mariota
was drafted the guy who drafted jameis
winston is still there in tampa bay so
he's got an incentive to sign this guy
to another contract and i think they're
going to will it to happen more in tampa
especially with bruce arians than in
tennessee with whoever the next guy is
to be the coordinator for a year before
he gets sucked up by another team the
way that that matt lafleur did so yeah i
think it's going to be winston although
there's a chance it's going to be
neither between the two i think
winston's got the better opportunity
i would say neither is probably the
smart choice by both teams i wouldn't
sign either of those guys with your
money mike even though you don't have
much
and here's the thing how many years do
you give a guy to become a franchise
quarterback i say there's three types of
teams in the nfl teams that have a
franchise quarterback teams that are
looking for one and teams that have a
guy and they aren't sure yet whether
he's going to be one what's the shelf
life i mean miami gave tannehill seven
years before they pulled the plug is fi
five has to be the outer limit it used
to be not that long ago i mean how long
did the bears give your guy kade mcdown
he had like a oh
three weeks to prove he could play so i
i think five years is a little much and
if you haven't declared yourself a
franchise quarterback by now it ain't
gonna happen
yeah well it's scary in the nfl to hit
hit the reset button also credit to you
mike's for just glossing over that
little one-liner i threw at you that's
how obsessed with football you are so
good for you
no i've learned that the best way to
deal with you is when you try to bait me
just ignore it just keep going i figured
it out after however many weeks it's
been i don't know how many weeks it's
been but uh
you're an anniversary guy you're gonna
like buy me a present when we hit the
three months that we've been doing this
together i have no idea when it started
i feel like i've been i feel like i've
been dragging this ball and chain around
for so long i forget when it started
don't make it awkward i don't want a
card
division champion most likely to repeat
your chicago bears or the dallas cowboys
i said it in the last segment i think
the the eagles are a lock in the nfc
east and and tell me why the bears
wouldn't repeat is it is aaron rodgers
and matt leflore going to become this
dynamite offense maybe i don't know they
added a lot on defense the packers would
be the team i would say are most likely
to challenge the bears i don't trust
matt stafford how dare you don't truck i
don't trust kirk cousins so
i think it's bears or packers i'll take
my chances with with the bears now i am
scared about the boogeyman aaron rodgers
on on primetime television starting the
season because only bad things happen
when that when he goes on prime time
against the bears but i take my chances
on the bears over the cowboys
the the vikings have become the ultimate
yo yo playoff no playoff team they are
due to make it to the playoffs because
they didn't last year they did the year
before they didn't the year before that
that's the way it's rolled under mike
zimmer since he became the head coach
and and with with gary kubiak there to
stabilize the offense and and protect
kirk cousins from himself to keep kirk
from becoming kurt cousins in those and
they're not going to have the same
number of prime time games that they can
that they can not win like they did last
year they were two and six in games of
consequence last year most of those were
in prime time i i think the vikings are
the team the bears need to worry about
the most this year i really do not that
that means the vikings are going to
topple them but i think that the vikings
are going to be back last year the
expectations were ridiculously high and
i knew they were going to fail this year
the expectations are very low and
they're going to be better than what
people think okay so let me throw that
right back at you mike florio you just
said that it goes back and forth yoyos
back and forth year to year the vikings
won't have a lot of prime time games the
expectations are low oh wait the cowboys
the nfc east changes every year yo-yos
back and forth every year they won it
last year they're going to have a lot of
prime time games the expectations are
high so you literally use the reasoning
for why the cowboys shouldn't win the
nfc east for why the vikings will
challenge the bears the nfc north i won
that
well no but see i was just trying to
make myself feel better about the
vikings chances for this year i agree
with you the bears have the better
chance to win the division because we've
already established that we think the
eagles are going to win the nfc east so
yeah i think the bears have the better
chance to win it so i'm i'm agreeing
with you i'm just trying to make you i'm
trying to make you nervous not just
about aaron rodgers i want you to worry
about captain curt cousins and and the
the the band of purple uh people leaders
in minnesota all right free agent
acquisition most likely to start in the
pro bowl last year none of the major
free agent acquisitions made it to the
pro bowl or at least not as starters who
who do you think of all the free agent
signings that have happened over the
past couple of weeks the most likely guy
to make it to the pro bowl
is antonio brown officially a free agent
under my rules under your rules he is
okay so antonio brown will be number one
um i wrote down four names le'veon bell
antonio brown
landon collins earl thomas i'm going to
go with landon collins in this that
seems like good player bad team pro bowl
yeah but bad teams have no pro bowlers
the really bad teams have none i like
our autonomous racers really bad they
won't be really bad i'm talking about
like they'll get wins six seven games so
they're not going to be really really
bad they'll be middle of the road and i
think landon collins would be the pro
bowler
you missed you missed the the obvious
defensive choice my guy tyron matthew
joining kansas city chiefs because
they're going to be great again and when
a team goes 13-3 12 and four whatever
they have like 10 pro bowlers all you
have to do is be a a member of the
starting lineup and you end up in the
pro bowl if you play for that team all
right we got to take a quick break when
we return
more on this josh rosen situation where
we think he may go and when
i think a trade is likely to happen if
at all more pft library after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports